bien que la situation demeure stable au
québec françois legault a dû défendre sa
gestion de la pandémie encore une fois
aujourd'hui face au tir groupé des
partis d'opposition et les accuse de
nouvelle fois québec de ne pas
communiquer les données scientifiques
sur lesquelles sont fondées les
décisions sanitaire françois legault lui
affirme n'avoir rien à cacher j'en parle
avec gabriel nadeau dubois co porte
parole de québec solidaire et paul st
pierre plamondon le nouveau chef du
parti québécois
bonsoir à tous les deux quand même dire
que nous avons évité la chef du parti
libéral du québec mais un conflit
d'horaire elles n'étaient pas
disponibles autrement leur était avec
nous comme on voulait réunir les coûts
porte parole où les chefs
voilà qui est dit par contre on a invité
chez pas le des dizaines de fois le
ministre de la santé et monsieur dubé et
on lui offre encore la possible de venir
avec la 60e beaucoup de question pour
lui
en attendant je m'adresser à vous
messieurs pourquoi vous accusé le
gouvernement de manquer de transparence
envers la population et après nadeau
dubois
parce que au moment au québec en matière
de transparence et on n'est pas les
parties de boules et pas seulement
québec solidaire qui le dit
il ya un consensus qui s'installe au
québec on a un gouvernement qui prend
des décisions qui fait des choix
c'est normal de faire des choix quand on
gère une crise par contre que les gens
ne comprennent pas pourquoi il fait
certains choix plutôt que d'autres et
pour justifier ses décisions devraient
donner à la population les données
scientifiques les données objectives
kill kill kimathi la partie wallonne il
le fait qu'un exemple de choix par
exemple où sont les éclosions fortement
au québec qu'on y en at il dans les jim
qu'on les y en a t-il des éclosions dans
les restos combien y en a dans les
musées comme il serrait dans les salles
de cinéma des endroits concernés et qui
pourtant à notre connaissance ne perd
pas des foyers d'éclosion de convives et
comment se fait il que pendant ce temps
nos des commerces ou des entreprises
comme un email
union des éclosions documenté reste
ouvert donc ces sessions d'écriture là
que beaucoup de gens dans la population
se pose est est ton courrier que des
oppositions les trois partis politiques
disent la même chose n'arrive pas tous
les jours soit l'assemblée nationale ça
arrive c'est parce que du côté du parti
québécois pour le st pierre plamondon si
vous enchaînez sur ce que vient
désagréable nadeau dubois c'est que vous
aimeriez que l'on consacre une sorte
d'autonomie d'indépendance de la santé
publique face aux politiques en fait
augmenté depuis deux mois de mai on a
averti mme aka dès le mois de mai si
vous voulez continuer à voir la
collaboration l'adhésion de la
population
assurez-vous de bien expliquer le
pourquoi des décisions alors comment ce
qu'on a à la cac
une cellule de crise composée d'un
docteur et de 17 spécialistes des
communications et de la politique et on
ne peut pas lorsqu'on écoute le
gouvernement comprendre le raisonnement
scientifique départager les avis
scientifiques de la décision politique
par exemple si notre gouvernement nous
dit c'est correct de passer leur win
mais c'est pas correct de faire du sport
d'équipé parce que la contagion et c'est
un risque trop important
on aimerait pouvoir entendre la santé
publique puis ensuite si le gouvernement
n'a pas suivi la recommandation
d''achat' être de bonnes raisons mais là
ce qui est inquiétant c'est qu'on sonne
à la population à tous - certains
groupes qui disent moi je veux je ne
veux plus collaborer j'ai pas assez
confiance pour continuer à collaborer
d'où notre intervention aujourd'hui de
dire pourquoi ce moment l'heure si le
gouvernement adopte en paix repose sur
les avis publics qui aura santé publique
note en paix repose sur la séparation du
scientifique et du politique est ce qu
on pourrait au moins avoir un
observateur scientifiques indépendants
qui vont aux réunions qui fait un
rapport de temps à autre à la population
sur le pourquoi des décisions parce
qu'en ce moment c'est d'une opacité qu
tels que plusieurs personnes remettent
en question les décisions la confiance
dans le fait d'expliquer le pourquoi
chaque décision sur le plan scientifique
session difficile à comprendre pour
certains certains groupes on pense à la
détresse dans le monde la restauration
par exemple
mon atelier dans le monde du tourisme en
général et l'industrie aérienne rest que
le gouvernement a fait des appels
quotidiens à la solidarité à comprendre
le règle toute simple c'est que plus eu
de contact il ya de risques de
contamination gabriel nadeau dubois est
ce qu'on a besoin d'en savoir plus pour
bien gérer cette pandémie en même temps
ce que vous nourrissez la méfiance de
ceux qui s'opposent aux mesures du
gouvernement
la confiance est au sens civique
le gouvernement nous dit depuis des mois
maintenant
faites nous confiance sabotier valu la
confiance ça doit être un dialogue et à
qu'en donnant dans la confiance de la
population dans l'eau doit faire
confiance à la population
tu as confiance que les québécois et les
québécoises sont assez intelligents pour
comprendre les deux scientifiques et
donc comprendre pourquoi le gouvernement
fait certains choix plutôt que non il
faut respecter l'intelligence des
québécois et des québécoises
après huit mois de produit je crois que
les gens sont capables de regarder les
données scientifiques et de comprendre
pourquoi ces choix sont faits en
maintenant une telle opacité en
maintenant un tel manque de transparence
je suis désolé mais fait le gouvernement
suscite de la mafia si le gouvernement
qui effrite l'adhésion de la population
à ces décisions
en refusant de donner l'heure juste sur
ce qui le motive scientifiquement clair
il faut que l'a4 à ce moyen de
communication politique et plus de
communications scientifiques et comment
ça se serait su apprécier pierre le
monde mais c'est peut-être important de
mentionner le cul ce qu'on veut ce dont
on parle en ce moment ça court dans les
autres provinces canadiennes calyon en
europe
donc tout ce qu'on demande c'est quelque
chose de très normal au niveau de la
manière de communiquer et ça se voit
donc se traduire par des amis de la
santé publique qui sont émis de manière
indépendante et l'on suit le
gouvernement lui prend ses décisions
mais la population que suivre le
raisonnement pour départager
l'observateur m
c'est peut-être plus de scientifiques
parce que on s'en crée en face du
gouvernement depuis le début pour
susciter l'adhésion c'est le marketing
politique des dépendances en
publicitaire d'une approche très très
axé sur les communications politiques
commenté moins de la composition de la
cellule de crise
mais est-ce que c'est dans les arènes où
elle a besoin des places est davantage
d'intelligence de sciences pour que les
gens continuent à suivre pour que les
gens se disent ok on comprend c'est
exigeant mais au moins on comprend de
vous qu'est ce que vous feriez mieux
marketing moi je vous arrête de parler
de marketing mais les médias sont
pleines les résolutions plein de
publicité dite de prévention pédagogique
pour rappeler constamment les les
consignes là qu'est ce que vous feriez
de mieux oublions de l'instant la
transparence si vous étiez aux commandes
gabriel nadeau-dubois qu'est-ce que
feriez de mieux pour faire adhérer la
population à ces consignes justement qui
sont très élémentaire au fond quoi les
choses faire comme en colombie
britannique est exactement où se
trouvent les éclosions un raidissement
ouais mais c'est pas un détail quand on
essaie de convaincre les gens
connaissaient pour vannes par exemple
les propriétaires de jimmy d'obtempérer
et de fermer leur établissement
d'ailleurs tout le monde veut que les
propriétaires de jim optant personnel
mais si on veut aller chercher leur
adhésion
mon portable des amendes et par la
solidarité qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
mais pour faire la démonstration
scientifique que ces lieux là sont des
lieux de 30 millions parce que oui il
faut diminuer le nombre de contacts
globe
le nombre total de contacts dans la
société québécoise
mais tous les contacts ne sont pas égaux
tous les contacts n'ont pas la même
dangerosité en matière de transmission
du virus
alors il faut documenter ils sont les
éclosions de l'ancien milieu de travail
dans quelle entreprise dans quelles
circonstances la confusion communautaire
ce produit et justifie à partir de ça
les décisions de confinement que l'on
fait donc oui c'est l'hommage final nous
deux
examen des stands passe à perdre et
c'est pour récupérer la dose d'humour
ouais je fermais l'andra qu'il est
normal qu'il y ait une certaine part de
jugement politique c'est normal que ce
soit les élus
après tout qui est le dernier mot et ses
décisions contre il doit s'appuyer sur
la documentation scientifique est ce que
québec solidaire demande comme beaucoup
de gens dans la série québécoise c'est
qu'on la voit ses documents personnels
quand tout à coup les choix de laisser
un peu de temps après sa période avant
d'en terminer brièvement doit simplement
donner d'autres exemples que la santé
publique pourrait m'expliquer quand on
est en jaune rouge ou en zone orange
puis qu'on constate très très peu de cas
sur une certaine période de temps
suivant quels critères on va revenir en
zone gens nous on va s'améliorer
expliquer aux gens suivant quels
critères les entreprises vont été
arrêtés au cours des prochaines semaines
c'est un lieu de manière à donner la
prévisibilité aux entreprises parce
qu'en ce moment tout le monde nage dans
le flou dans le gris parce que la santé
publique ne joue pas son rôle de dire à
l'avancé quels critères objectifs grosso
modo recluse et donc la population les
gens d'affaires particulièrement se font
surprendre constamment par les avis du
gouvernement qui arrive à la dernière
minute ce sont des choses que lorsqu'on
regarde dans votre pays que la santé
publique sur une base scientifique et
objective 1 pour faire pour tenter de
rendre la situation plus prévisible
mieux comprise également dans la
population mais vous encourager quand
même
pour l'instant les québécois à suivre
les consignes et où jim à rester à
respecter les quotidiens dans ce coin
très claire des besoins continus quatre
abris mais on pense qu'on va l'avoir est
davantage c'est transparent bersin on
aurait donné mais évidemment que tout le
monde continue à collaborer sur lui
merci gebre l'ado dubois merci pas saint
pierre le monde on s'en va